-Thank you for coming by
and coming back.
I have so many things
to talk to you about.
There are so many projects
that you do.
-A lot of content.
-You are so hot right now.
I can't even tell you, man.
Thanks for doing that bit,
by the way,
earlier in the show.
You're a good man.
But you have "Addams Family 2."
You have "The Card Counter,"
which I want to get into.
I want to talk about "Dune"...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-"Dune."
-..."Scenes from a Marriage."
I'm not completely finished
with it yet,
but you're so good
-Oh, thank you.
-in that thing
and Jessica is so great
in this thing.
Gosh,
you guys crushed that one.
-It's heavy stuff.
-Ooh! It's heavy stuff.
-Yeah.
-But I mean, when you
do these intense scenes,
what do you do to just unwind
or just go like,
"I just need a break"
or do you sit in your trailer,
or what do you do?
-Yeah, well, we had these rooms,
like greenrooms,
because we were just filming
in this --
it's like an old warehouse.
It's a studio, now,
up in The Bronx.
And so we had
these two little rooms
or individual little setups
in there.
And so sometimes Jessica and I
would sit on her couch
and have tea and watch
"The Great British Bake Off."
[ Laughter ]
-Is that how you...?
"Great British Bake Off."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, sometimes she --
-It is calming.
-It's really calming and sweet,
nice people.
-That's the best.
I love hearing that story.
And then, sometimes
with maybe potato chips
and "Succession,"
that we would watch.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
Dude, I'm getting ready
for "Succession."
-Oof. I can't wait.
-Right?
-Can't wait.
-It's going to be good.
-It's going
to be good.
-Can I talk about "Dune"
for a second as well?
Now, "Dune," it's massive.
-Yeah.
-How do you get involved
with this?
Are you a fan of the book?
Are you a fan
of the film?
-It's a book?
[ Laughter ]
Did they make a book
out of it already?
-Yeah, the book came
-Fast.
-after the movie.
-They make 'em fast, nowadays.
-Dude, yeah, but how do you
get involved in that?
Just they call you and they go,
"Hey, we love ya"?
-No, I called --
I write to Denis and I say,
"Hey, I hear you're doing
'Dune.'
Big fan over here."
And then he wrote back,
"So you're a fan of Dune.
Interesting."
[ Laughter ]
That was it.
Didn't hear anything
for two years.
[ Laughter ]
-You're joking.
-No.
-That's the worst.
-And he reached out
and said that, you know,
"Here's a script.
I'm not sure exactly
where you fit into it.
Read it.
Tell me what you think."
And so I read it.
And I already had a sense
that like Duke Leto, the dad,
that's kind of, you know.
The way he's even described
in the book is olive-skinned
and, you know,
the high cheekbones.
And I just knew there was
a beard waiting
[ Laughter ]
to be explored.
-You have the best beard game
in the business.
-He walks in beard first,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Any room.
-Of course.
-And so I was ready
to unleash that one.
-But, when I first met you
and you were like this,
sans beard,
and then, I see you with a beard
and, man, I was like jealous.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, man.
You guys, have you seen this?
-[Indistinct], right?
-No, I got a patchy.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm.
-Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please, for this beard?
[ Drumroll ]
♪♪
There you go right there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-You got a real beautiful
beard over there.
-Tariq's got a good beard.
He's got a good beard
game going,
but that's what I'm talk
about, right there.
"Dune" beard
is what I'm talking about.
And I know, in the film,
Timothée Chalamet
is your son.
-He's my little boy.
-That's hilarious.
"My little boy."
-My sweet little baby boy.
[ Laughter ]
-How did you guys bond?
-I just would hold him a lot.
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
-He was the best because,
you know, it's like,
I can't just be like,
"I'm your dad."
[ Laughter ]
-Of course not.
-So he's got to
treat me like that, you know?
And it's that old adage,
you know, from theater school
where it's like
the king doesn't show
the audience who the king is.
It's the court
that tells the audience
who the king is, you know?
-Ah.
-It's because it's
how everybody else acts.
-Correct.
-And so he immediately
just like, went there with it
and, you know,
it just shows what a,
you know,
talented and beautiful
actor he is.
-I was going to say,
did you play him any lullabies
that you play to your son?
[ Laughter ]
-We played a lot of music.
We did. We did.
He was playing a lot of guitar
at the time,
so we would, you know,
we'd trade some songs
back and forth.
-I know you're a musician,
but I mean,
you play some lullabies
for your son.
-I do.
-Yeah.
And is your wife --
-Well, I used to.
He doesn't like them anymore.
-He's out?
[ Laughter ]
-He's out.
He's not into it anymore.
-What were the songs about?
-You know, it's like
all the old crap, you know,
like "The Wheels on the Bus"
and the...
-Classics?
-Yeah, all the classics.
He just wants to hear the hits.
[ Laughter ]
-So he lights a lighter.
He's like, "I'm tired.
I heard this one."
-I got a lot of originals,
but he just, you know,
he's just not as into them.
-What are the originals?
-You know,
"Elephants Are Kind to People."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's a good one, yeah.
-"The Hippopotamus Song."
Although, that one,
the little guy is really into.
And I feel like he's coming
around to it now,
the older one.
-"The Hippopotamus"?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean,
and it's just you on guitar?
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-And singing and --
-I'm just saying because...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You want me
to sing you a lullaby?
-Would you?
-Alright. You guys want
to hear the hippo song?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Want to hear the hippo song?
Here, here's a pick, right here.
-Alright, a pick, too.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, [indistinct]
[ Laughter ]
So, well, here's the thing.
I remember I played it
for Jessica's daughter
and she started crying.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no!
-So it can be intense, too.
So it's, you know, little boys.
-I'll go in with an open mind.
♪♪
Yeah, it's the hippo song.
It's about the hippopotamus.
The most dangerous land animal
in the world.
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
♪ Hippopotamus ♪
♪♪
♪ Ahhhhhmp! ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm a hippopotamus ♪
♪ I like swimming,
but I'm dangerous ♪
♪ If you get too close to me ♪
♪ I might just
bite your feet! Oh ♪
♪ Hippopotamus ♪
♪ I'm a hippopotamus ♪
♪ I'm
a hippopotamus ♪
♪ I'm fat and dangerous ♪
♪ If you don't understand ♪
♪ I might just bite your ♪
♪ Hand! ♪
♪ Hippopotamus ♪
-I like this jam.
-♪ Hippopotamus ♪
♪ Hippopotamus ♪
-Oscar Isaac,
"The Hippopotamus Song."
-♪ Whoo ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oscar Isaac!
More with Oscar
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
♪♪
♪ Hippopotamus ♪
That's a good jam, dude.
♪♪